[Música]
terminó la más reciente edición de la
conferencia de seguridad de Múnich la
capital bávara reunió a personalidades
de todo el mundo como es habitual Cada
año los pongo rápidamente en contexto se
trata de una reunión anual que comenzó a
ser realizada en 1963 y es un foro
independiente reúne acerca de 350
figuras de alto nivel a escala
internacional procedentes de más de 70
países y el fin de este encuentro es
simplemente debatir sobre los desafíos
de seguridad que se están presentando en
la actualidad este año el foco como era
de esperarse fue la guerra en Ucrania
las repercusiones que este conflicto ha
tenido a nivel internacional también los
participantes estuvieron de acuerdo en
la necesidad de fortalecer justamente la
defensa de Ucrania para lograr repeler
la invasión rusa y también Buscar
mecanismos para terminar con este
conflicto en el este de Europa en esta
edición a la que Rusia por primera vez
no fue invitada Estados Unidos acusó
directamente a Rusia de crímenes contra
la humanidad veamos
en el caso de las acciones de Rusia en
Ucrania hemos examinado la evidencia
conocemos los estándares legales y no
hay duda
eso son crímenes contra la humanidad
a punto de cumplirse un año del inicio
de la invasión rusa a Ucrania hay varios
puntos que preocupan a la comunidad
internacional Uno de ellos es que a
nivel logístico y militar Rusia no haya
mostrado toda su capacidad por eso la
urgencia entonces de fortalecer al
ejército ucraniano algo en lo que la
Unión Europea se mantiene firme y
dispuesta a dar todo su apoyo a kiev
tenemos que redoblar esfuerzos y Tenemos
que continuar con el apoyo realmente
masivo que es necesario que estos planes
imperialistas de Putin fracasen por
completo Este es un objetivo que Ucrania
es capaz de ganar
otro temor Es que la guerra se prolongue
en el tiempo se vuelva una guerra
abierta y con altos y con bajos pero sin
fin como es la guerra de Siria por
ejemplo y que este tipo de estrategias
por parte de Rusia se extienda a otras
regiones es decir este intento de Rusia
de crear un nuevo orden mundial que
todavía no hemos podido entender bien
Cuál es ese concepto de orden mundial se
convierta en una excusa para desarrollar
más conflictos en otras regiones
Las Guerras son impredecibles y no
sabemos cuándo ni cómo terminará esta
pero si sé esto Incluso si la guerra
termina mañana nuestro entorno de
seguridad ha cambiado a largo plazo no
hay vuelta atrás el kremlin quiere una
Europa diferente Una en la que Rusia
controla a sus vecinos
también sabemos que Beijing está
observando de cerca el precio que paga
Rusia o la recompensa que recibe por su
agresión lo que está sucediendo en
Europa hoy podría suceder en Asia mañana
tomorrow el fin de esta conferencia
también coincide con la visita del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
de manera sorpresa a kiev Allí se reunió
con el presidente bolodimir lensky
viendo las imágenes de los dos
mandatarios Caminando por la capital
ucraniana qué Pensarán los rusos en este
momento ante la acusación por parte de
Washington hacia Moscú de realizar
crímenes contra la humanidad esto que
resonancia puede tener a nivel
internacional y qué repercusión va a
tener para Rusia en esta conferencia
podemos decir en esta conferencia de
seguridad puntualmente será El Punto de
partida de un nuevo capítulo en la
Guerra de Ucrania o se configurará una
nueva defensa de Ucrania de Cara a una
posible incursión a gran escala por
parte de Rusia como temen que va a
suceder en la primavera pues se lo vamos
a preguntar a nuestros invitados y
analistas del día de hoy para conversar
sobre este tema hemos invitado Australia
iscan ella es especialista en seguridad
y política internacional y también según
esta conversación Javier Rentería él es
investigador asociado de global colts de
la universidad rameo Yule también es
especialista en estudios críticos de
seguridad y militarización les recuerdo
que ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales ya lo saben estamos
en Twitter en Facebook y en instagram
nos encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral el debate f24
todo junto a mí me encuentran como
arroba santilogo en Twitter no olviden
también que todos los contenidos de este
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
le doy entonces la bienvenida a atalia
en la Ciudad de México gracias por estar
con nosotros hoy en el programa talia y
cuál es el balance que puede hacer y el
análisis que le deja esta conferencia de
seguridad de Múnich bienvenida
Hola Santiago Muchas gracias por el
espacio
pues Cabe destacar que la conferencia de
Munich claramente es un instrumento
importante en términos de analizar
política internacional y seguridad
internacional Pero por otro lado tú
mencionaste un un nuevo juego en en
términos de la configuración de la
estrategia de la guerra Pues antes que
nada claramente se generan muchas
narrativas pero lo que nosotros buscamos
en ese escenario si lo que buscamos es
Construir la paz Antes que nada es un
diálogo con Rusia Entonces estamos
hablando de una reunión sin presencia de
Rusia únicamente por organizado por
parte de los países occidentales
entonces claramente está el discurso
occidental está un heroísmo entrañano y
está todo todo el reclamo por parte
Ucrania de pedir más ayuda militar pero
si realmente queremos entender que va a
ser Rusia o cómo va a avanzar esa guerra
se me hace también un poco un poco
importante el esfuerzo en términos de
predecir la guerra pues es una guerra
sin fin y también Cabe destacar que es
una guerra multidimensional Así que hay
que hay que visualizarlo en en términos
de la seguridad humana es decir
seguridad alimentaria seguridad
económica seguridad personal el tema de
los refugiados el día de hoy estamos
hablando de siete punto dos millones de
refugiados entonces también está una
crisis humanitaria y en esta conferencia
se habla únicamente parte de comercio de
armas y solo estamos viendo parte de
Ucrania yo creo que claro el problema
porque se dice que la guerra es
impredecible pero la parte rusa o no
occidental siempre ha argumentado que
era bastante predecible ese movimiento
Entonces yo sí lo veo relevante pero no
no tan no tan cambiante o no tan crucial
en términos de la pacificación Claro
pues vamos a hacerle la misma pregunta a
nuestro siguiente invitado a Javier
bienvenido Gracias por estar con
nosotros vamos a conocer también su
opinión el balance y el análisis que
hace usted una vez finalizada esta
conferencia de seguridad en The Munich
en baviera en Alemania que tuvo como ya
lo decíamos punto central la guerra en
Ucrania
Bueno Hola a todos un placer estar aquí
con vosotros
mi balance sería similar al realizado
por Tania realmente
ha sido una conferencia entre la que ha
faltado uno de los grandes protagonistas
de la segunda internacional que es Rusia
y por lo tanto
los grandes ejes que suelen llevar esta
conferencia dirigir la conferencia que
suelen ser el nexo de seguridad
desarrollo la seguridad energética
también
temas sobre la cómo los autoritarismos
están aumentando en entorno a la
seguridad y a las opciones de este
llamado nuevo nuevo orden mundial que se
quiere que se quiere establecer pero
básicamente las desde el ámbito europeo
especialmente la narrativa que sea que
se ha defendido en esta conferencia ha
sido la de tratar de establecer las más
rápidas para el mar a Ucrania
y establecer también canales de
coordinación entre los países europeos
tanto para enviar entre Ucrania y
también para aumentar
las europeas
sin embargo Sí cierto que la falta de
Rusia y en cierto modo las otras otras
voces de del sur global también
algo que que han hecho la
presidental
ha tratado de abogar por una respuesta
diplomática hacia este foro y se puede
ver en las respuestas de los países
latinoamericanos hacia la militarización
y las y las ayudas hacia Ucrania con
parte de armamento Cómo se ha tratado de
limitar ese tipo de narrativa y ese tipo
de vías Javier continuó con usted para
hacer la ronda la inversa los dos creo
que coinciden en que
un punto importante era la presencia de
Rusia Qué diferencia podría haber tenido
esta conferencia a la que habitualmente
Rusia es invitada año tras año para
hablar de los temas de seguridad y ahora
creo que la comunidad internacional no
le puede reprochar a Moscú si en algún
momento tiene algún tipo de reunión
similar a esta con alguno de sus países
aliados ya sea china ya sea Corea India
para hablar justamente de tema
internacional porque ya la comunidad
digamos el mundo occidental se ha
reunido precisamente para ver cómo armar
a Ucrania para defenderse de Rusia Rusia
en un balance de guerra Pues podría
estar en un escenario en donde pueda ser
exactamente lo mismo Javier
Sí bueno lo que lo que podemos
ver lo que hemos visto También en esta
conferencia más ha sido la reunión que
han mantenido tanto Anthony blinken como
bungie los
secretarios de exteriores de ambos
países y la verdad se ha tratado de
establecer también una un Bueno un nuevo
marco para esta para esta situación que
es la rivalidad creciente entre Estados
Unidos y China y la posible o el aumento
desde la alianza estratégica que está
teniendo tanto Pekín y Moscú y cómo se
va a traducir esto en el contexto
ucraniano claro Quiero conocer la
opinión de de Thalia Qué diferencia
habría tenido este encuentro con Rusia
presente
Gracias pues primero que nada tendríamos
oportunidad de conocer la política
exterior rusa respecto al tema militar
ahorita y Cabe destacar que por ejemplo
en los tiempos de once de septiembre de
crisis de terrorismo Putin tuvo mucho
acercamiento con el bloque occidental
pero después de las tensiones de Ucrania
y euromaidan hubo un alejamiento súper
drástico es decir Rusia se aisló y
también los potencias occidentales
elitizaron los ámbitos y las
herramientas de seguridad
internacionales por eso que es
claramente difícil adivinar ahorita con
quién Qué tipo de reunión va a llevar
Rusia pero aquí las rivalidades son
importantes y yo también sumo el poder
de Irán y otros actores que han sido
sancionados o no escuchados o poco
representados por parte de la comunidad
internacional wesfaliano y yo creo que
sí es complejo Entonces si hubiéramos
tenido un representante de Rusia sería
una reunión relevante pero sin una sin
una representación rusa Pues la verdad
es que no es una reunión homo no es una
reunión neutral simplemente es como otro
otro plataforma donde los europeos están
como expresándose sus narrativa de la
colaboración y demás comercio de armas
pero a final de cuenta Cabe destacar que
es una guerra Proxy es decir es una
enfrentamiento No únicamente entre
Ucrania y Rusia sino también entre Rusia
y todo el bloqueo occidental entonces a
final de cuentas y solo seguimos
hablando de armas ignoramos todo el tema
de seguridad humana quién logra Estados
Unidos y Quién pierde toda la región
europea por tantas amenazas y riesgos
que está recibiendo el día de hoy que
poco a poco va a estar teniendo defecto
en otros continentes también sí creo que
coinciden en que prácticamente esta fue
una conferencia de seguridad para
Ucrania más que para la los intereses
internacionales que habitualmente son
los temas que que hay que mirar en
perspectiva en este tipo de conferencias
año tras año es mirar Qué problemas de
seguridad hay en la coyuntura del
momento Y en este momento pues
se identificó digámoslo así un enemigo
común y una y un país al que deben
ayudar en ese orden de ideas talia
continuó con usted y lo mencionaba yo en
la introducción del programa se está
reconfigurando a raíz de esta
conferencia una nueva estrategia de
defensa para Ucrania para esa posible o
supuesta gran incursión militar que va a
ser Rusia en la primavera y todo esto se
concentra en un solo punto armas para
llevar al frente para llevar al este de
Ucrania como lo analiza usted La verdad
es que lo analizo este desde una visión
bastante crítica Incluso hoy hablamos de
470 millones de euros de posible ayuda
que vayan este mandar Entonces si lo
vemos desde la perspectiva militar vale
el Europa está dejando muy claro como a
Quién apoya Pero por otro lado si lo
vemos este parte intereses globales tal
como tú mencionaste no es un no es un
movimiento pragmático porque este
movimiento de resistencia se pintó como
pero desde un inicio es una guerra de
inbalance es decir estamos hablando de
un país con mucha desestabilidad y una
infraestructura este completamente
destruida contra una potencia nuclear a
pesar de que haya recibido muchas
sanciones y ha tenido muchos perdidos
económicas Rusia sigue siendo una
amenaza nuclear entonces aquí hay hay
una hay como una imprudencia política
por parte de la narración internacional
yo creo porque si estamos buscando
negociar Y si estamos buscando que que
menos gente se muera en esa región No
únicamente ucraniano sino todas las
minorías que habitan en esta región
posoviética bastante vulnerable Pues yo
creo que se tiene que crear más foros de
negociación Entonces yo lo veo bastante
complejo y así mismo va a haber más
resistencia pero con que haya más
resistencia Rusia también va a usar más
recursos logísticos en cualquier momento
puede tocar este botoncito rojo de armas
de La amenaza nuclear Y eso sería lo
menos conveniente para toda la región
claro Italia dejemos sobre la mesa el
tema de la diplomacia y la negociación
lo dejó para analizarlo un poco más
adelante en el programa Quiero
preguntarle a Javier justamente Cómo
puede reaccionar Rusia Rusia es un país
bastante enigmático entender lo que está
pasando por la cabeza del presidente
Putin ha sido bastante enigmático a lo
largo de este año de incursión militar
en el este de Ucrania cuando occidente
cree que Rusia va a ir para una zona
Rusia se mueve para otro lado y siempre
está La amenaza nuclear ellos mismos lo
han dicho desde el kremlin lo han
mencionado varias veces que puede ser
una unas bajo la manga en cualquier
momento han destacado ese poderío
militar que tienen y también hay cierto
temor de que Rusia pues tal vez no ha
demostrado todo su potencial nuclear en
este Perdón su potencial militar en esta
guerra en el este de Ucrania
sí Bueno realmente se podría hablar
ahora de una especie de
estancamiento relativo en el frente a
pesar de que los combates continúan
sí que es cierto que es una como bien ha
comentado tallia es una es una guerra
Proxy multidimensional y en la que el
balance de fuerzas está tremendamente
desfavorable en contra de Ucrania sí sin
embargo estos últimos meses hemos podido
ver sobre todo viendo el desarrollo de
dónde se han realizado las las ofensivas
rusas en tres principales ejes en el
norte en crimina en el en el centro en
torno a backmud y en el sur en torno a
bulevar y estamos viendo como quizás
esta este en esta en esta fase del
enfrentamiento en la que el invierno
está siendo es crucial para para lo que
es la guerra de movimientos y la guerra
mecanizada Rusia Está tratando de lo que
es interrumpir ese flujo de
soldados ucranianos que están yendo
siendo entrenados en la retaguardia o
bien en países de la otan para obligar a
Ucrania en este momento a tener que
llevar en base a una a unas ataques de
atrición para llevar a soldados rusos
que se está a soldado ucranianos Perdón
que se están entrenando en la
retaguardia y obligar así a Ucrania a
utilizarlos y por el lado ucraniano
a
está siendo obligado a mantenerse con
las tropas que tenga la línea al frente
hasta que la la famosa o la gran
esperada ofensiva de primavera mayo
ambas fuerzas se vean con capacidad para
llevar tanto operaciones militares de
armas combinadas y se llega a un punto
en el
que ambos bandos puedan encontrar
espacios o ganancias militares lo
suficiente para sentarse a la mesa de
negociación Javier en este momento pues
ya entendemos china Perdón Ucrania Con
quién está respaldado la Unión Europea y
Estados Unidos es un bloque inmenso que
respalda Ucrania pero en este caso Rusia
tiene a China como un Aliado pero aquí
que tanto margen de acción tiene China
para poder respaldar a su Aliado en el
kremlin en términos militares o china
simplemente dará un apoyo
digámoslo en el discurso más que en la
práctica cómo lo puede analizar
bueno pese a las a la reticencia china y
de repetir sobre todo el mensaje de que
esta guerra no no les involucra Es
cierto que china ha estado involucrada
desde desde el primer momento
especialmente en el ámbito financiero y
en el ámbito del comercio Para apoyar a
China para poder dar salida a todas esas
materias primas que no estaban siendo
enviadas a Europa y por el por el por el
otro lado por el lado del armamento que
es quizás el tema más controvertido en
la en la misma reunión que tuvieron
los
los jefes de exteriores tanto chinos
como como estadounidense
Anthony blinken marcó como una de las
líneas Rojas el apoyo en términos de
munición y de armamento de China a Rusia
como una de las de las como una de las
áreas en las que China de ser parte de
este conflicto de una manera más activa
no debería no debería tomar porque
Estados Unidos
ha querido decir que tomara nota de este
asunto Italia su opinión sobre el papel
de china en todo este asunto
creo que desde el inicio de la guerra
ha sido importante la postura de China y
en el contexto de la guerra ruso
ucraniana que que ha generado mucha
bipolaridad a nivel mundial el simple
hecho de abstener en muchos debates o no
sancionar también refleja una postura
Pues yo creo que tienen un enemigo en
común Rusia y China más que sean Súper
Amigos tienen el enemigo en común
Estados Unidos en esa competencia y en
ese nuevo escenario del tablero mundial
Entonces yo creo que sí tiene un papel
muy importante china hasta el momento se
ha llamado mucho la atención al tema de
foros de negociación tal como otros
países mediadores principalmente Turquía
sería uno después de los esfuerzos de
del tratado de granos etcétera entonces
yo creo que sí china
es una amenaza para las potencias
occidentales y para Rusia es una
oportunidad porque también es un país
que conlleva varios temas políticos a
nivel regional e internacional Antes que
nada pues yo creo que todos podemos
prever el problema de Taiwán que va a
ser un problema No únicamente
geopolítico sino también de toda la
narrativa un problema que otra vez va a
intimidar la narración y la prepotencia
de de las de la zona occidental y
también como como mi compañero
mencionaba Pues el el sur global no está
representado en los foros de decisión
entonces países como China y Rusia
todavía tienen más voz en el sur global
porque son países que no se pueden
categorizar como países desarrollados
desde una visión pero tampoco son no
desarrollados porque llevan cierto
liderazgo o cierto como
ciertas superpotencia en ciertos temas
tal como china en tecnología Rusia en lo
militar etcétera entonces yo creo que sí
Estados Unidos está va a estar
enfrentando una decadencia pero tampoco
va a ceder su parte de su industria
militar que es lo más fuerte que tiene
ahorita y es por eso tanta insistencia
en el tema comercial de y China yo creo
que va va a pegar más por por el parte
económico tecnológico y de la narrativa
política cree usted talia que china va a
ser ese actor internacional fundamental
que va puede llevar a kiev y a Moscú a
una mesa de diálogo o esa gran apuesta
sigue siendo Turquía o Turquía que ha
sido un país que ha jugado un rol
importante en todo el conflicto ha
ofrecido su territorio para diferentes
mesas de diálogo sin un éxito Porque si
uno pues no estaríamos en este en este
escenario pero Turquía Ahora tiene un
escenario interno muy complicado y es la
secuela del terremoto y fuera de eso las
elecciones presidenciales el tema de
Ucrania tal vez ya no es la importancia
en este momento para los turcos ni para
el gobierno de erdogan
creo que tuviste un análisis muy
importante Pues yo la verdad es que no
creo que china reemplazaría a Turquía
porque China y Rusia también en ciertos
temas llevando igualdades y para que
china sea un país mediador Antes que
nada se tendría que liberar de muchos
problemas que tienen no tal como el
problema de los huigures el problema de
Taiwán etcétera entonces no creo que
china sea el país mediador porque
tampoco la comunidad internacional lo
aceptaría como un país mediador a
Turquía lo aceptaron porque Turquía
geoestratégicamente está más cercano es
un país miembro de la otan y también no
es un país este que ha tenido relaciones
muy estratégicos con Rusia Entonces no
creo que china tomaría esa papel pero
por otro lado yo Yo igualmente dudo que
Turquía tome un un activismo tan
importante dado que está enfrentando
ahorita la crisis más catastrófica del
siglo el país en la región en en la
frontera con Siria y o sea va a estar
teniendo como muchas prioridades en su
agenda interior Pero eso no quiero decir
que china va a tomar el liderazgo yo
creo que china simplemente allá va a
estar como respaldando Rusia en algunos
cuestiones y absteniendo en algunas
cuestiones aquí Lo importante es que no
sean aliados sino que china esté en
contra de Estados Unidos y también cabe
recalcar que China y y Estados Unidos
actualmente se encuentran en una guerra
económica nunca hablamos de esos tipos
de enfrentamientos Porque siempre nos
importa lo tradicional lo maquiavélico
lo de armas pero también está esa
rivalidad Entonces yo creo que china sí
es un jugador muy importante pero no en
términos de mediador sino en términos de
crear nuevas alianzas junto con Rusia y
otros países aislados o excluidos de la
comunidad internacional
Javier Tenemos que hablar de la
estrategia que se está jugando en este
momento y la gran apuesta es armar a
Ucrania para que Ucrania tenga la
capacidad militar para hacer frente al
avance ruso sobre todo en la región del
donbas y en el sur del país En dónde
queda entonces la diplomacia porque los
organismos internacionales y bloques
como por ejemplo la Unión Europea que
siempre la apuestan un poco más a la
diplomacia y al diálogo en este
escenario Tal parece que la diplomacia
ni siquiera la tuvieron en cuenta a la
hora de conversar en este foro
sí ciertamente la verdad que la Unión
Europea y puedo decir también Incluso el
cierto público europeo
en cierto público político Se podría
decir que todavía no está preparado para
llevar a cabo la para llevar a cabo la
vida diplomática ya que todavía
tanto especialmente por el por un grupo
de países de Europa del este liderado
por Polonia no se sienten con con la
capacidad o con la confianza suficiente
hacia Rusia como para sentarte Y tratar
de establecer términos para una
negociación o una Paz pactada en este
sentido el vicepresidente Europea y jefe
de la diplomacia exterior lo dijo
claramente ayer en la conferencia del
Múnich en los ucranianos reciben muchos
aplausos pero poca munición claramente
ahora mismo desde la comisión europe y
especialmente desde los países
del este de Europa que son los que más
amenazados se sienten evidentemente por
por la agresión de Rusia a Ucrania se va
a tratar y se continúa todavía tratando
llevar a a más esta escalada militar y
ejemplo de ello es el constante o el
constante incitación tanto por Polonia
pero por otros países incluido por
ejemplo Holanda de llevar a cabo el
envío de cazas de combate f16 a Ucrania
por lo que la verdad se puede decir que
todavía el escenario tanto narrativo
como político no está no está listo o no
está maduro todavía como para ir a una
mesa de negociación y teniendo en cuenta
que en el final al final solo es
ucranianos los que los que deciden
sentarse en esa mesa y si aceptar
y son finalmente los ucranianos los que
están yendo al frente de batalla porque
aquí no hay tropas internacionales
metidas en territorio ucraniano luchando
con los ucranianos son los ucranianos
los que están poniendo el pecho y la
frente para poder combatir en terreno
llama mucho la atención posiciones Como
por ejemplo la de Estonia que hace un
llamado a la Unión Europea a hacer una
compra en conjunto de los 27 países
compran conjunto de armamento para
enviarlo a Ucrania yo creo que esto no
había un precedente en en conflictos o
en escenarios similares donde un país
fomentara que todo el bloque de la Unión
Europea comprara armas cuando siempre se
fomentaba el diálogo creo que aquí nos
da para analizar algo importante tal y
Javier y es justamente la democracia
este concepto de democracia del diálogo
está desgastado está agotado cuando se
se toma iniciativas como esta como la
que vimos en esta conferencia de Munich
en donde se le apuesta al combate y a la
militarización en vez del diálogo esto
que precedentes nos puede dejar para
futuros conflictos en algunos años
Italia
creo que la verdad O sea el término de
democracia lleva muchos tiempos con con
un significado perdido es decir todos
los bloques Siempre han empleado el
término de democracia para justificar o
desjustificar cualquier acto y tal como
tú también previamente mencionaste con
mi compañero Pues según Europa por sus
valores y por toda la integración
regional avanzado que lleva
tiene la tiene la costumbre de promover
la diplomacia yo veo diplomacia nula y
pura hipocracia o sea entonces es
bastante complejo porque según si
estamos buscando generar más foros de
diálogo Y si los ucranianos son los que
van a decir mandar más armas no es la
solución porque con que mandan todos los
armas que tienen
no van a poder generar un escenario
igualitario por el tema nuclear que no
podemos ignorar desde el inicio como
hemos Entonces por ejemplo todo el tema
de los tanques o tipo los las armas de
nueva tecnología sí pueden este
empoderar la defensa ucraniana Pero eso
no nos lleva una solución a finale
cuenta la solución se tiene que dibujar
en términos de derecho internacional
público y estoy hablando de un tratado
siempre después de cualquier conflicto
vamos a regresar al primero Guerra
Mundial Segunda Guerra Fría necesitamos
acuerdos es decir necesitamos más marco
teórico y quiénes son los que nos
proporcionan las instituciones pero si
nuestras instituciones
internacionales toman partidos y allá
están provocando los actores los dos
frentes de una guerra cómo vamos a
llegar a la paz entonces simplemente es
la impotencia de las instituciones y las
las mentiras atrás de los discursos de
democracia porque al final de cuentas al
parecer ni los países europeos tienen
amigos tienen intereses en la región
no han jugado hoy suficientemente
inteligente es por eso que Rusia no ha
cedido y sigue con ataques muy agresivos
sin compartir su plan Sí eso Italia que
creo que entonces desvirtió
completamente este este foro esta
conferencia de Munich que empezó como
decía en en 1963 justamente para acercar
a Estados Unidos y a la entonces unión
soviética para generar un espacio de
diálogo entre las dos partes debido a
esa atención nuclear que había entre los
dos y era un escenario que no estaba
respaldado por ningún tipo de organismo
internacional era completamente
independiente hoy en día Pues eso ha
cambiado y vemos cómo está conferencia
pues ha tomado una Clara tendencia
debido a la coyuntura que estamos
viviendo importante también analizar no
lo puedo dejar de mencionar Estados
Unidos en toda esta negociación en toda
esta conferencia Javier y sobre todo
importante esa visita del presidente Joe
biden aquí hoy para darle y mostrarle el
completo respaldo que tiene Estados
Unidos hacia Ucrania
Estados Unidos sigue aprovechando la
posición geográfica privilegiada de no
estar en Europa de ver el conflicto
desde el otro lado del Atlántico pero sí
enviar militarmente y siempre estar
apostando por
proveer suministros de armas a Ucrania
pero ellos no están en el terreno
sí Bueno a mí lo que me está recordando
un poco la postura de biden o la
narrativa que está tratando de
establecer es un poco la narrativa de
Roosevelt de esta armar a las
democracias Y tratar de establecerse
como un poco pastor de las democracias
liberales que tan amenazadas se ven
ahora mismo
es cierto que como coincido con Thalia
que y contigo Santiago que que este
marco normativo este marco basado en La
Paz liberal de en el que se basaba tanto
la proyección exterior de la Unión
Europea como el apoyo a las
instituciones internacionales ha ido
evolucionando en los últimos años
especialmente
tras el brexit la llegada de Trump y y
lo que supuso eso en términos de que los
europeos trataran de establecer esa
Independencia estratégica esa brújula
estratégica que se presentó el año
pasado y se ha tratado de establecer
un cambio de de basado en la seguridad y
el desarrollo hacia un marco más
pragmático basado en la estabilidad y la
contención de las amenazas en un en un
mundo geopolítico que está en una
creciente competición y en la que no
solo Ucrania sino que en distintos
escenarios Como por ejemplo en ese gel o
en el centro de África podemos ver cómo
está aumentando la competición de estas
de estas potencias que tratan de
establecer en este nuevo orden
multipolar su su versión un poco de Cómo
deben llevarse a cabo las relaciones
internacionales tallia Javier me quedan
ya un par de minutos para finalizar el
programa se fue muy rápido y bueno este
tema nos daría para muchísimo para un
programa mucho más largo quiero que
hagamos las conclusiones de lo que deja
entonces esta conferencia para cerrar el
programa Y de lo que viene para Ucrania
Cómo se reconfigura entonces a raíz de
estas decisiones tomadas en Múnich Cómo
va a afectar esto el conflicto A qué nos
vamos a estar enfrentando en las
próximas semanas en terreno en Ucrania
comienzo con Javier dejó atalia para el
cierre
sí Bueno yo creo que en las últimas
semanas no vamos a ver grandes cambios
en lo que es en los en los en los
frentes ya que ahora mismo se está en
una fase de parada táctica para retomar
otra vez las operaciones una vez estén
todas las unidades relativamente
operativas pero lo que todo apunta a que
en los próximos meses vivamos una una
escalada tanto en la intensidad como en
el número de combates en Ucrania
precisamente Italia su conclusión para
el cierre del programa qué sigue en este
conflicto en pocas palabras sigue una
guerra sin fin Rusia creo que va a estar
recibiendo más sanciones a nivel
económico eso va a ser un reto y va a
aislarse más en los ámbitos
internacionales y Ucrania pues ya vemos
que está pidiendo ayuda de fondo
monetario internacional sin embargo Cabe
destacar que programa de ajuste
económico de estos instituciones también
este intervienen en los asuntos internos
por lo tanto estamos hablando de un país
que ya perdió su soberanía y por otro
lado Cabe destacar que sin presencia de
Rusia los foros independientes o
internacionales tal como conferencia de
Munich no son relevantes porque lo que
buscamos es es un foro de debate para
entender los dos partes y ejes más
importantes en esta guerra
independientemente y que sea bueno o
malos porque también son términos este
subjetivos esa conferencia es
irrelevante y se va a generar más
discurso pero yo creo que hay que
enfocarnos más en lo que nos espera urge
urgen actores mediadores ahorita que
Turquía enfrentó sus propios problemas
yo creo que nos estamos Buscar más más
actores neutrales para que proporcionen
foros relevantes de debate donde Rusia y
Ucrania pueden participar y negociar Sí
pues Natalia y a Javier les agradezco
mucho por haber estado con nosotros en
el programa haber analizado esta
coyuntura para la audiencia de France 24
en América Latina España y es todo por
el momento En nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos su sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera sigan sintonía France 24 siga
con nosotros
[Música]